[Music]
hello everyone
persia here and today we are playing
immortals phoenix rising
on stadium because there is an exclusive
demo out now until
october 29th one of the coolest things
about stadia is that you're always
one click away from the games you want
to play and you can play anywhere
instantly and what better way to show
that off than to call up a couple of
friends
we're going to be joined by greg miller
from kind of funny games and andrea
renee
from what's good games to break down
this demo
and see what we're gonna get to
experience on december 3rd
to kick off our demo is gonna be andrea
renee so let's just go ahead and get
started i'm super excited to play today
and if you guys want to play then go
ahead and just click that link in the
description
it's just that easy all right let's do
it the sun
rose on the palaces and temples of the
golden isle
so jumping into this demo you know
what's something that you're really
looking forward to trying out i really
loved
when britt did the preview for what's
good games
she talked about a lot of gameplay
mechanics that felt inspired from the
assassin's creed franchise and so i'm
just excited to see some of those
combat influenced mechanics and also
some of the traversal mechanics as well
yeah for me listen to the blessing talk
about it
it is about this beautiful world to go
run around and explore
see what's over that next to cliff's
edge right go into this story that
they're doing
obviously you know prometheus talking
now there's so much to
get into in this game i'm excited for
more the rpg thing part of it
stop fantasizing about random nobodies
and tell the real story what real story
so we have our narrators here we have
zeus and prometheus and they're like the
ones kind of carrying us through
narrating our story what do you guys
think about
their dynamic to the story i think it
gives them
a different take than we usually see
them
i love that they're kind of
making it seem more like it's comedic
than it's the serious mythological quest
because we've got that before right
yeah 100 i think that you know these
greek mythology are stories we know so
well right that i think taking a new
spin on it making it this
uh dueling banter of what is actually
happening
sets this game apart from even something
you know coming off of assassin's creed
odyssey and coming into this
it looks like we are about to jump on in
here
and honestly phoenix is totally
amazing like she's super powerful
demigod
anyone in there i've spent so little
time with phoenix as a character
i don't know if she's the humble hero
if she's more of like a braggadocious
kind of a hero
or if she's going to grow into
the legend that i assume that she's
going to become by the end of the game
right we don't really know who phoenix
is because this is
her first time being in a video game but
that's the power of the game andrew you
get to pick how she'll be and who she'll
be and how braggadocio
i think that's what's going to be
interesting today of splitting the demo
in half and seeing you know how
andrea would tackle this world uh versus
how i will when i get my hands on it and
see you know
the different play styles and a way to
approach enemies and puzzles and
encounters
so how's the combat feeling so far we
saw you know sword attack
r1 are you feeling different timings in
the attacks or are
you going for it you know so far um the
dodge feels really good
the light attack which is the r1 button
um feels really responsive
the heavier the heavy attack actually is
it's what's nice about it is that it
feels powerful but it doesn't feel like
the animation
takes a really long time to swing you
know you gotta assert your
demigod power all right feeling good
okay so let's keep moving forward
there's no one around though so oh wait
what wow
wow i have a i have a mount friend
amazing oh my gosh yeah
[Music]
wait okay okay okay interesting so my
mount friend
oh disappeared but now i'm gliding
appeared on her back
by the god the flying was something i
saw really early on in the trailers and
early gameplay footage that caught my
eye because you know it's a
beautiful landscape of course but
obviously it looks like it's going to be
a big part of traveling and getting to
different areas yes
so this is really exciting from an
exploration standpoint the idea that not
only
do you get to explore the skies as well
but you get to explore underwater too
exactly and you already found a chest
down there so you know
it's worth exploring because you're
gonna find some goodies too oh yeah i'm
a trash panda if there is a chest to be
opened
i will open
i wonder how long in the game it's gonna
take me to
upgrade to the amount of stamina that i
have right now right this is not the
very beginning of the game you know it's
giving us
a good taste of what you're going to
experience when you play
but also not everything that you're
going to experience ooh
you got this andrew thank you
oh nice oh and we got that nice little
animation
all right
give me the treasure
oh a new weapon triple damage with sword
air combo
[Laughter]
all right continuing on
see this is my favorite part about the
glide is that i can be
up in the world like that really
exploring the verticality of the level
design
and then if i'm like okay i have to get
back to my objective here i can just
poof
off the edge i don't have to find a way
down
i'm trying to help you exactly
oh blue mushroom oh okay oh i see so if
i'm
climbing up a really tall surface and i
need to keep going i can collect these
mushrooms along the way to keep
refilling my stamina that's nice
i heard a shiny thing
listen i told you i was a trash panda so
i need to get the shiny thing
no this is perfect nice that's
gonna go full sneaky
oh no oh
all right our foes are getting
progressively more intimidating
he's just taking a little nap oh he's
back he's awake
okay out of there
hello friend yeah i was like that's our
friend from earlier right now
remember when you killed me
oh you tricked me
oh and did i say
this enemy is a little bit of everyone
now
now zeus it's awesome they can't decide
yeah they can't they're narrating
so now we're just going to fight a bunch
of roosters
bring it on okay
okay haphazard's hammer i'm into it
boom
the power behind this hammer we're
eating wings tonight boys
chicken dinner let's go
[Music]
it feels like a little bit of overkill
for these chickens but
i don't know okay the only way to do
that
is with herbs i'm saying this as a
friend
you need to cool it with the herbs
oh they made a herb joke
okay so um i think here's where we're
switching the demo okay
my time to shine yeah all right all
right miller
i'm tapping you in all right we've
officially
switched over just like that and now
greg
is taking over on the demo but we're
getting a chance to see something a
little bit different than the combat
we've seen so far and it's looking like
some puzzles which i love
yeah this one's got an eye on it so i
know everybody chill out when you play
it on your own you can put it where you
want but i'm putting it right there so i
can see if it works at work
got it nice
[Music]
one to go ooh can you open that
yeah yeah
i love the open animations for the
she's had a few different ones so far
already
oh yeah we're getting that oh my
goodness those wings are so cool
there we go all right let's see what we
got going on here
you know a little bit of remodeling here
[Music]
all right you have the final orb
prepare it's gonna be a kill screen
everybody it's gonna be credits here in
a second
success
[Music]
that is a very fancy harp
oh my favorite part about opel world
rpgs put these
giant objects into your magical pockets
don't worry about it
or die trying awesome so it looks like
we have
a new weapon a new item we have
the uh the bow oh i didn't get to play
with the bow
on a pixel finished the
job yes nice
excellent and then to the skies yes
so like the leaves and the particle
effects that are
floating around got the new wings
equipped too
ah so you see phoenix uncovered a set of
targets
if you looked at these had carried this
so we're making our way
back to where we started and kind of
traversing in the opposite direction
so it looks like we have another puzzle
you know
tucked away here in the landscape and
our narrators
are pretty good at kind of hinting at
where there's something
nearby so let's see if we can figure
this one out
ah right
oh i see because now they've changed
color
yeah now they're not red and i'm i'm
going through and do and making them
blue
and i'll end in that fire pit so there
you go we did a whole bunch of different
things we figured it out okay see now
you're on fire already
yeah see we learned yeah i was on fire
it was from shooting from a specific
spot injury when i shot from the actual
arrow icon
who would have thought it did what i was
supposed to do stand on it yeah
there we you go it
thank you thank you let's go see we got
in that chestnut
they really set it up nice too with the
light shining from the back like you're
really running up to some glorious gear
right now
oh you got a new bow that's exciting
i like how greg's like i don't need no
staircase i'm just going to climb the
surface of this
i'm taking the direct route all right in
the real game that's when i'll play it
safe that's when i'll carry all those
other stuff
okay good i was gonna say you're playing
that stamina
gamble but you have plenty of stamina
potions so you're good
andrew we're on game spot this is how
you live you get out there you see what
happens
i feel like this meter has not moved
the with the little lightning bolt is so
i don't know
if your objective is actually at the top
of this thing
but it's still cool now it's very
clearly telling me to go down so no it's
not at the top but we're almost at the
top now we're not stopping
but the grape is we'll be able to jump
off of this and fly exactly i'm going to
glide right into it
well wait you're talking about your
stamina
there's nothing cool up at the top of
this hand
the view the v is cold
you got a shiny
and now we arrive in style exactly
ooh i like that the the speed glide
oh yeah she's about to hit him with the
tunes
this is gonna be a fight isn't it
it's almost like the game's like do you
want these potions that buff your
defense and your attack
you're about to need them
forget the lasers here oh that is a big
health bar
oh okay he just picked up that filler
he sure did
oh nice dodge
hit him with a you want hammer to drop
the hammer
yes see it's a massive damage there
nice we were just like man look at this
health bar
and then a few godly abilities later
he's hurting there we go
it's almost like zeus knows us
[Laughter]
tell me y'all's final thoughts you know
now that you've
been able to run around in the world a
little bit and really get a feel for it
what do you think
i think immortals phoenix rising looks
like some of the best
cherry-picked parts of other action open
world rpgs that we have seen
over the last couple of years all mashed
into a really
fun experience i think one of the really
unique things that we've seen so far in
this demo
is not only the combination of combat
and traversal mechanics really
marrying nicely but also the art style
is something that
i think is really great as well it
really gives a fresh take
i think it's beautiful i think it's
really fun to play it's fast it's fluid
like this is something that i am all
about like
this open world run around like we were
talking about right like your quest is
all the way over there and on the way
there you run into you know three or
four other things to do let alone
treasure chest let alone crafting
and then put that moment to the moment
gameplay that uh boss right there this
you know how satisfying it is to
dodge the perfect attack and then come
in and get them that's that's a lot of
fun
well thank you guys so much for joining
me today
playing a little bit of immortals
phoenix rising and getting a taste of
what we're gonna see
on december 3rd now this game is going
to be out
pretty much everywhere on december 3rd
but if you're trying to dive into this
demo
then it's exclusive to stadia from now
until october
29th so go ahead and click that link in
the description if you want to hop into
it and have some fun thank you guys so
much for everything and we will see you
later